[Music]
underrated let go
hot route daryl henderson
[Music]
i'm worried that the camera has exploded
[Music]
oh what is up what is good how you
living how you feeling this is
underrated i
am adam lefkow this is the first show
ever that allows nfl players to improve
their madden ratings
it's brought to you by state farm in
their surprisingly great rates today
i got off the couch i came to california
to see daryl henderson
because he is having a surprisingly
great season i don't think people know
about it
especially madden and we're going to get
those ratings out
and i think he's here now let's go talk
to him
hey look at you getting ready
how you living i'm good how are you how
you doing i'm i'm enjoying this la air
right now this is beautiful
what's not beautiful is your madden
rating it's
bullcrap and i don't like you're a 73.
i don't know what's going on do you
think you're underrated i do
like i've been honored my whole life
still is all right well we're gonna do
some stuff today to get that rating
out let's get it okay you sure i'm ready
okay i got a guy named clint he's the
guy we have to talk to okay
all right let's get this going there he
is
clint my buddy old pal how you feeling
buddy
hey i'm good how are you doing lefko i'm
good
this is my good friend daryl henderson
you may know him he's on the rams he's
having an
incredible season this year yes i i know
who daryl is how you doing daryl nice to
see you going good how you doing doing
well what can i do for you guys today
i've told them you're the plug and i
want to fix two ratings i want to make
them
sky high because i think my man is
killing it this season
first one ball carrier vision where
is he right now and what do i need to
have him show you to bump it up
so his bulkheart vision rating currently
is a 77
currently ranking him 107th
do you think my friend is blind and they
got the practice ward in front of me
yeah
practice squads in front of them what's
the deal clint max mainly because
we don't have a ton of reps on daryl yet
but things that we're looking for in
bulkheart vision
uh speed at which you find cutback lanes
yardage efficiency
getting through holes quickly just
maximizing that burst through the line
which i know is one of daryl's strengths
the second thing is apparently my guy
has an absolute
arm cannon i want to focus on throw
power
that's that's a great question i don't
hear that one much for running backs
i could give you a pretty sizable
increase in throw power if you could
throw
over 60 yards easy i'm gonna have them
do all the things you asked
we're gonna send you the footage you're
gonna bump up the ratings and we're all
gonna be smiles i appreciate you clint
okay i can't wait to see it guys okay
now that he's off the phone
let's smoke this okay yes
let's go
it is throw power time you feel a little
cocky about this don't you
no i'm just confident he's just
confident let me bring it down to size
because we are comparing it
to your madden character have you seen
yourself throwing madden yet
no it's not a pretty sight let's take a
look there he is
27 daryl henderson drops back throws
and that's about as far as you can throw
40 yards daryl henderson is that
insulting to who you are as a person
yes i'm insulted for you if you throw it
further than 40
your rating goes up the further you go
the higher it goes up because
okay get this out of here it's bad
evidence
are you ready okay
[Music]
daryl there is no way your madden
character is throwing that far
look at daryl with the beautiful throat
i think that was further
does that feel good yeah
[Music]
oh that's the one i got to do some
push-ups this is intimidating
all right this is the last one do you
think you can hit
70. there's no
[Music]
get there get there get there get there
get there what did it hit jacob
the 11 69.
how does the cannon feel good man c and
this is why his ratings need to go up
because he is willing to tire out his
arm in a game week
for underrated okay so we know that you
can throw it but if we're really going
to change your madden rating
i need to see the vision that ball
carrier vision we don't have your
offensive line
but i do have these guys
so here's how we're going to do this i'm
getting under center i'm bringing it
back
and when you get the rock they're going
to open up wherever the hole is
hit it and then juke out the linebacker
can
does this sound good to you i'm with it
i'm ready
let's go
okay see daryl henderson hike
[Music]
hey
[Music]
i think we need to embarrass the camera
i think whatever you do on this next
move
just embarrass it
underrated let's go hot route
daryl henderson
[Music]
i'm worried that the cameras exploded
madden
i mean we're breaking cameras to improve
this rating
all right this is the last one ea clint
this is a big one oldenburg clint
holdenberg
carol henderson
[Music]
way to beat that role man
all you did was break a camera today
proud of you
how'd it feel i felt pretty good all
right tell the people first how were my
hand-off skills
it was great except when i went that way
right he had a little difference
again uh offensive line was great you
threw it deep
showed off the arm cannon overall do you
have a message for the people of ea
i get my reigns up stop playing with me
stop playing with him
daryl henderson get the ratings up now
clint buddy pal i've missed you a lot
and i'm so excited because daryl
henderson is
showing everybody this season he's the
most underrated i know you see the stiff
arms
hey he is coming up man i i wish the
rams would commit to him a little bit
more
getting more carriers in that backfield
but he is opening some eyes for sure
i'm loving it and now i need you to say
this to his face that he's underrated
let's get daryl henderson on the call
my guy daryl i mean listen ever since
i've seen you've been killing people
dude it's amazing to watch man we're
proud of you
where he said clint first thing
throw power oh my gosh so that was
impressive
i didn't know that he had an arm on him
like this he threw almost 70 yards in
the air on both throws
so his throat power is actually going up
22 points
to a 55 and he's now the fourth running
back in throw power
right below a teammate of his who's a
former quarterback
cam akers yeah we might have to have a
throw off in the rams backfield here
uh clint we got the the sumo wrestlers
out there
the offensive line for some ball carrier
vision
was the tape good enough to improve that
for you
daryl was already increasing based on
his game film this season
he's now going up to an 80. he's going
to now be ranked 63rd
among all running backs in baltimore
vision so he's moved up 44 spots in ball
carrier vision since we last spoke
daryl your thoughts off to a good start
but uh
i think i'm about a 92
that's not all based on the teeth
there's a bonus point
awareness awareness is also going up one
point
that will raise your overall rating
daryl so you've moved up to a 75 overall
with all of these updates
let's go i'm saying you're underrated
social media is saying you're underrated
clint is daryl henderson underrated
daryl henderson is underrated and if i
could i want to make a plea to coach
sean mcvay get the ball in this guy's
hands a little bit more i want to see
more of him
i gotta keep working keep improving
daryl so proud of you and candidly
the only thing more surprising than your
phenomenal performance this year clint
what is it
insurance exactly the surprisingly great
rates of state farm
that's underrated and that's one heck of
a segue daryl henderson way to go pal
[Music]
you like what you just saw subscribe to
bleach report on youtube for more
underrated